hello everyone and welcome to another
very fun game you guys requested it's a
short one but it shows you what happens
when you try something weird against the
uh the world champion here in this game
will have a completely new position
already as of move four uh but you'll
see uh what I mean by this so Magnus
wins the first two games and now this is
the third game again Magnus with the
white pieces like in game one and he
opens with E4 we have C5 by shakaria
Knight to F3 we have E6 going for the uh
for 46 Sicilian and now a C4 Magnus goes
for The Chronic variation he grabs the
full center now the D5 is under his
control uh and here you can continue
this uh many different ways Knight the
C6 is the most standard idea you could
also play Knight to F6 uh you could play
Pawn to A6 you could place a queen to C7
so there are many moves you can try here
and many moves have been played here but
here uh mamidarov plays Pawn to G5 and
it's a move that has only been once been
played once in 2007 in a game between a
1900 player and a 2000 player uh where
where black just lost yeah and in that
game D4 was played but the D4 kinda
plays right into why black plays G5 if
you play D4 here you don't have the
standard captures captures because uh
black will just kick away your knight
and once you move the Knight OKC
captures on D4 Queen captures attacks
the rook and queen F6 and already you
are playing Black's game but in the game
after G5 Magnus just played Ponte H3 and
he now asks what is the Pawn on G5 doing
I'm playing you D5 D4 next and I'm gonna
attack it and okay Bishop to G7 uh we
have D4 striking in the center captures
captures and now Pawn to A6 okay now the
Knight is on D4 so you cannot capture on
G5 but Knight to C3 by Magnus and now
Pawn to H6 with Bishop to E3 uh
interestingly Magnus is playing this uh
every move is uh the the top engine
recommendation we have Knight to E7 and
now comes Pawn to H4 just uh threatening
to win a pawn here so G captures an H4
Rook captures an H4 and now Pawn to D6
and now Magnus goes Queen to D2 he just
adds a third attacker to the H6 pawn and
it's a really really weird setup black
has the usual uh pawn moves that you
would see in a Sicilian Defense A6 D6
and E6 but there's no G Pawn uh which
would kind of make sense maybe if you
had a rook and a g file but you have a
fianchetto bishop on the G file that's
undefended not not as great so Knights
the G6 goes after The Rook Rook the H5
and now Knights the D7 sort of inviting
Magnus to go after Bishop captures on H6
but Magnus just plays Bishop to E2 he
says I don't have to rush this there's
no way for you to actually defend the
dh6 pawn Knight to F6 attacks the rook
and now Rook the H3 and here Shakir
should just uh sort of count His
blessings and he should Advance the pawn
to H5 save the pawn and just continue
the game somehow let's say castles Queen
to C7 and the dream that he can maybe
play Bishop to D7 castles King to B8 and
sort of survive this position but in the
game he played Queen to A5 it's
defending the H6 Pawn with a tactic
because now if Magnus captures an H6 you
can just go for for all the traits here
captures captures captures and captures
and then capture an E4 as the queen on
A5 now uh ends the C3 knight from moving
but Magnus after Queen A5 just plays
Queen side castles and now Bishop to D7
mommy jar of ready to jump to that Queen
side with the King and now Magnus throws
a big slap in the face with Knight to B3
uh attacking mamajaro's Queen and kind
of asking him to move uh back to Queen
to C7 or queen to d8 or maybe Queen to
B4 but Shakira played Queen to E5 and
now uh the position just falls apart so
feel free to pause the video and figure
out what mamidyarov missed here while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
queen is in fact trapped all of the
squares available to the black queen are
not available to the black queen as a
white um uh covers all of them and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to F4 now just in case
any of you consider the bishop to D3
this is the top engine move uh that
defends the E for Pawn uh so so it just
prevents black from even capturing an E4
and F4 is still Unstoppable so if you PL
if you even consider the bishop to D3 uh
there is a genius hidden inside you but
okay F4 if you're a human F4 is
perfectly fine you you don't have to see
something like this as now the queen is
trapped there's nothing to play even if
you try to give up the night here
characters captures the queen is still
trapped you haven't really done anything
with that Knight capture so Shockley
have tried Knight captures on e4 but not
magnet just plays F captures and E5
Knight characters on D2 and as he
captured the queen mamidarov also
resigned the game so it was in this
position on move 18 that shahir
mamajarov resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once Knight
captures on D5 and Bishop capture Sun E5
if you count the pieces and Magnus is
just up a full night so of course this
is completely unplayable uh so it was a
sort of a mix of maybe trying I doubted
that uh Mama dear had this prepared as a
surprise for Magnus I think it was a
more of a I'm already losing two to zero
so I have to try something radical and
I'm not really getting the positions I
want I have to try something radical to
get back into the match and it didn't
really work out as unfortunately for my
middle of Magnus played all the top
engine moves in refuting this weird G5
idea but it's a nice line for like
bullet or hyper bullet or maybe even
three minute Blitz above that it would
be it would be hard to pull it off
because after G5 and H3 you have a
sicilian setup with a weird Pawn on G5
so
maybe you could make something out of
this but it's just it seems very hard so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely played by Magnus
for those of you who are interested I
will show you the standings after the
first three days of the military
Champions Chester finals uh it is none
other than Magnus Carlsen and youngstov
Duda who are leading the event uh with a
perfect course nine points each then
with four points Anish uh pragnananda
and Liam Lee and with three point shaher
mamidarov and the Wesley so Arjun ergasi
for the moment still with zero points so
we'll have we'll we'll see what happens
the big Clash of Magnus versus Duda is
coming up so we'll see what happens in
that one uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh try weird ideas
but maybe not against the world champion
and good things might happen uh so yeah
I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Nadine Bernal G and I would
like to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
Harry Barton and Mario's clinic and
Francis air for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day